reprenons nos
travaux avec les auditions budgétaires
après la ministre de la Culture hier
soir nous recevons aujourd'hui madame
Amélie ouea Castera ministre des Sports
et des Jeux Olympiques et paralmpiques
pour nous présenter les crédits
budgétaires de son ministère pour
l'année
2024 nous vous retrouvons madame la
ministre pour évoquer les défis associés
à cette année si particulière qui selon
le dossier de presse de votre ministère
doit ni plus ni moins je cite marquer un
tournant pour la place du sport dans
notre pays les Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques leur organisation les
résultats obtenus par nos équipes de
France les modalités d'accueil des
délégations étrangères et des centaines
de milliers de touristes sur notre
territoire contribueront on ne peut que
l'espérer bien entendu au rayonnement
sportif culturel et touristique de la
France dans une période loin d'être
exentete de toute incertitude pour ne
pas dire de menace mais au-delà de la
préparation de ces jeux que nous suivons
depuis 2022 par le biais d'une mission
d'information conflié à Claude k Claude
Kern et David Assouline et des moyens
exceptionnels destinés au financement de
leur réussite c'est bien la place du
sport dans notre pays qui comme vous
nous préoccupe au plus haut point
l'héritage que les Jeux Olympiques et
par olympique de Paris doivent laisser
et qui doivent permettre et qui doit
permettre à nos pays de passer un cap en
matière
sportive nous nous félicitons bien
entendu de votre volontarisme en ce
domaine et des annonces qui se succèdent
et c'est bien normal au long de ces
années préolympiques la reconduction du
passeport qui permet d'accompagner le
processus de reprise des licences dans
les clubs tout comme la poursuite du
plan en faveur du développement des
équipements de proximité qui permet de
renforcer la diversité de l'offre sur la
période
2024-226 constitue des annonces que nous
accueillons évidemment de manière
positive mais nous ne pouvons masquer
nos inquiétudes madame la ministre dans
d'autres domaines qui nous paraissent
pourtant conditionner le développement
de la pratique du sport dans notre pays
je pense en particulier aux opérations
relatives aux 30 minutes d'activité
physique quotidienne dans les écoles
dont la mise en œuvre est contrastée
selon les établissements et que nous
entendons bien contrôler l'année
prochaine ainsi qu'à celle intitulé 2
heur de sport supplémentaires pour les
collégiens rester à ce stade il faut
bien le reconnaître assez confidentiel
pour paraphraser la devise olympique ne
convient-il pas d'aller plus vite plus
haut et plus fort dans ces domaines en
lien étroit bien entendu avec votre
nouveau collègue de l'éducation
nationale pour donner au sport la place
qui devrait être la sienne à l'école je
vous propose madame la ministre comme
nous avons l'habitude de le faire dans
un de vous laisser la parole pour un
propos liminaire afin que vous nous
présentiez les principales orientations
de de votre budget et puis après bien
entendu chacune des sénatrices et
sénateurs présents pourront vous
interroger et vous poser directement les
questions et je commencerai par
le le rapporteur pour les crédits du
sport Jean-Jacques loszac et ensuite le
président du groupe d'études sur les
pratiques sportives et les grands
événements sportifs Michel Savin et puis
chacun de ceux et celles qui voudront
intervenir bien sûr le pourront je
termine ce propos madame la ministre en
vous précdant que cette audition est
captée et diff usé en direct sur le site
du Sénat et je vous rappelle puisque
nous avons pris la bonne habitude depuis
hier de mettre un chronomètre pour nous
orienter pour être le plus concis
possible bien sûr nous mettrons le
chronomètre voilà madame la ministre la
parole est à
vous merci beaucoup merci monsieur le
Président
Laffond monsieur le rapporteur spécial
pour avis cher Jean-Jacques
LAAC mon monsieur le Président du Groupe
d'étude et de suivi Monsieur Michel
Savin mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs le 8 septembre dernier une
année sportive historique pour notre
pays a débuté avec l'accueil de la Coupe
du monde de rugby qui est un très beau
succès même s'il s'est malheureusement
achevé plutôt qu'espéré pour notre 15 de
France accueille également des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques et l'État
soutiendra pas moins de 50 grands
événements sportifs internationaux d'ici
2027 à travers ces événements et nos
politique publi l'horizon est clair
réaffirmé par le Président de la
République que la France devienne une
nation sportive un horizon qui se
rapproche d'ors et déjà avec ce projet
de loi de finances pour 2024 qui est
marqué par une progression de 7,3 % des
montants alloués aux politiques
publiques du sport qui atteignent ainsi
un niveau sans précédent les crédits
prévus sur le programme 219 le programme
sport ainsi que les plafonds des taxes
affectées alloué à l'Agence nationale du
sport atteignent un montant de près de
890 millions d'euros en hausse de 60
millions d'euros sur le même périmètre
la hausse depuis 2020 est de plus de 65
%. disons-le aucun gouvernement n'avait
auparavant conduit une politique
sportive aussi ambitieuse pour notre
pays sur le programme 350 jeux
olympiques et paralympiques qui porte
les subventions allouées d'une part à la
solideo pour les ouvrages olympiques
d'autre part au cojot pour
l'organisation des Jeux paralympiques
les crédits sont conformes à la
trajectoire prévue avec une baisse
programmée d'un petit peu plus de 160
millions d'euros entre 2023 et 2024 qui
est en cohérence avec la diminution
progressive des besoins sur les
chantiers
olympiques au-delà des moyens
budgétaires la dimension fiscal de ce
PLF apporte d'autres leviers
d'attractivité pour le sport dont
certains étaient attendus de longue date
le rétablissement du taux réduit de TVA
à 5,5 % sur les activités d'enseignement
dans les centres équestres favorable à
la pratique sportive féminine notamment
l'application d'un taux de TV à 5,5 %
sur la billetterie des pour les
spectateurs aux compétitions de eSport
aligné ainsi sur la billetterie sportive
et la billetterie culturelle l'extension
aux fédérations Sportiv internationale
du cadre fiscal déjà mis en place pour
les organisations internationales sur un
mode à la fois d'attractivité mais aussi
de
proportionnalité pour que la France
devienne cette nation sportive à
laquelle nous irons ensemble il nous
faut d'abord avec l'ensemble des
collectivités nous donner les moyens de
construire et de rénover nos équipements
sportifs c'est le sens du nouveau plan
5000 terrains génération 2024 annoncé à
hèse le 5 septembre dernier par le
Président de la République qui s'inscrit
dans la dynamique du succès du premier
plan 5000 terrains de proximité lancé en
octobre 2021 et dont le déploiement a
été finalisé en 2 ans soit une année
d'avance une dynamique qui a été
construite main dans la main avec les
élus locaux et qui transforme
concrètement la vie sportive de nos
concitoyens dans les territoire je sais
à quel point vous y avez été vous-même
attaché à ce plan le nouveau plan
génération 2024 bénéficie de moyen sans
précédent puisque c'est désormais une
enveloppe non pas de 200 mais de 300
millions d'euros qui est consacré à ses
rénovations ou à la construction de ces
équipements sportifs de 2024 à 2026 un
plan qui sera tourné vers nos clubs mais
aussi vers nos publics scolaires dans un
contexte monsieur le Président lapon où
le développement du sport à l'école doit
en effet être érigé en priorité
nationale c'est un peu la mer des
batailles au global d'ici à
2027 c'est plus d'un milliard d'euros
j'insiste plus d'un milliard d'euros que
que l'État aura mobilisé en faveur des
équipements sportif en s'appuyant sur
l'ANSS pour se faire auquel s'ajoutent
les dispositifs bien connus de vous et
de nos élus locaux les crédits descil et
DETR à hauteur de 250 millions d'euros
ils le sont retracés dans le jaune
budgétaire mais aussi le fond vert dont
70 millions d'euros ont déjà pu
bénéficier au sport avec 280 projets
correspondant à 15 % de l'enveloppe pour
la rénovation thermique des bâtiments et
des équipements
sportifs pour répondre à un besoin
régulièrement remonté là aussi par les
collectivités territoriales je veux
souligner l'excellente nouvelle que
représente aussi la réintégration dans
le champ du fond de compensation de la
TVA du fameux compte de 112 agencement
et aménagement de terrain notamment
sportif demande qui a été entendue et
pour laquelle je m'étais personnellement
mobilisé au côté de la première
ministre être une nation sportive c'est
aussi évidemment permettre le
développement de la pratique et ce dès
le plus jeune âge c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous l'évoquions à l'instant
l'école est désormais au centre de nos
politiques publiques sportives avec un
déploi que oui il faut parfaire de nos
30 minutes d'activité physique
quotidienne pour l'ensemble des élèves
du primaire 100 % de nos établissements
doivent assurer cette généralisation
contre de l'ordre de 85 % aujourd'hui
selon les dernières enquêtes remonté du
terrain avec la DG SCCO l'accélération
du déploiement des 2 heur de sport
supplémentairire pour les collégiens est
également une priorité majeure à
laquelle nous consacrons dans ce budget
près de 15 millions d'euros pour réussir
cette montée en puissance que vous
appeliez de vos vœux monsieur le
Président et passer d'une première étape
de 170 collèges embarqués à une étape en
2023 de 700 collèges puis ensuite en
2024 2000 collèges et vous avez en tête
que le Président de la République a
annoncé une généralisation du dispositif
à l'horizon de
2026 trè brique essentiel l'extension du
Pass sport initié en 2021 avec
l'ambition de réduire partout les
inégalité sociale financière dont on
sait que trop souvent elle freine la
pratique
sportive un enjeu là aussi auquel je
sais que vous êtes particulièrement
sensible et je voudrais souligner que
nous avons cette année notamment ouvert
le dispositif du passeport aux
associations jeunesse et éducation
populaire à travers tous les territ
de notre
pays ce budget traduit d'autres
priorités en termees de promotion de la
pratique sportive je pense à la
promotion de la pratique sportive
étudiante doté de plus de 1 million
d'euros supplémentairire du sport en
entreprise du sport féminin ainsi que de
la pratique sportive des personnes en
situation de handicap pour laquelle nous
avons d'ors et déjà de bons chiffres des
nouvelles encourageante en terme
d'évolution à travers l'organisation des
Jeux la la France souhaite que le sport
soit aussi un facteur de progrès un
moteur pour faire progresser la société
sur le plan de l'éducation on vient de
l'évoquer mais aussi de l'inclusion
sociale et de la santé tout en
continuant à démontrer sa capacité à
apporter de vrais réponse aux grands
défis contemporains je pense par exemple
à la transition écologique ou encore à
la lutte contre toutes les formes de
violence et de
discrimination sur chacune de ces
dimensions ce projet de loi de finance
permet d'accroître l'action et la
dynamique permise par le sport je pense
notamment à l'exemple du sport santé
avec 6 millions d'euros supplémentaires
pour développer les maisons sport santé
à travers les territoires qui
bénéficient aux personnes en situation
de maladie chronique ou de perte
d'autonomie pour financer également un
nouvel appel à projet du fond
interministériel pour l'amélioration des
conditions de travail sur la lutte
contre la sédentarité en milieu
professionnel je pense à la reconduction
des moyens supplé suémentaire déployé en
2023 à hauteur de 10 millions d'euros
sur le champ social tant pour
l'insertion par le sport que pour la
reconversion des sportifs de haut niveau
je pense enfin au moyens supplémentaires
pour que les services déconcentrés du
ministère des Sports renforce leur
action régalienne avec plus 36
équivalents temps plein en 2024 faisant
suite au 20 obtenus en 2023 dédié à la
lutte contre le séparatisme et la
radicalisation ainsi qu'au traitement
accéléré des dérives en matière de
violence à caractère sexiste et sexuel
dans les territoire nous stabilisons
également le volume des conseillers
techniques de sport dans les fédérations
au cours des prochaines
années évidemment toute cette dynamique
en faveur d'une nation sportive ne sera
pleinement réussie que si à l'occasion
de nos jeux olympiques et paralympiques
nos sportifs tricolores s'illustrent
nous font vibré et ramène des médailles
c'est cette ambition que nous
poursuivons avec l'Agence nationale du
sport depuis 2019 qui s'appuie sur le
réseau de l'INSEP des CREPS mais aussi
sur la stratégie de haute performance
ambition bleue ainsi que le sur le
programme spécifiquement dessiné gagn en
France deux initiatives dont les crédits
ont connu une augmentation de près de 7
million d'euros dans ce PLF avec un
objectif central réussir notre objectif
de nous inscrire durablement dans le top
5 des nations les plus médaillé et pour
ne pr ne se priver ne nous privé d'aucun
levier pour atteindre cet objectif
ambitieux nous avons intégré une
revalorisation significative des primes
au médaillés ainsi qu'à l'encadrement et
pour que l'avantage de jouer à domicile
devant les siens il fonctionne à plein
dans notre pays à l'été 2024 nous avons
fait en sorte de consacrer des moyens
supplémentaires pour animer au au plan
local dans tous les territoires ce
chemin cette route vers les jeux en
déployant à cette fin 4 millions d'euros
supplémentaires de crédit d'animation
territoriale enfin pour parachever sur
le plan sociétal la réussite des jeux
2024 mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
vous l'avez en tête sera l'année de la
Grande Cause Nationale pour la première
fois en 40 ans dédié à l'activité
physique et sportive et que j'aurais
l'honneur de présenter à l'occasion du
prochain Salon des Maires car je veux
que son ancrage territorial soit d
l'origine affirmé sans ambage une grande
cause qui sera dotée de moyens inédits
plus de 10 millions d'euros inscrits
dans ce budget cette grande cause nous y
reviendrons sans doute vise plusieurs
objectifs continu à inscrire au cœur du
pacte républicain et des politiques
public le sport comme un moteur
incontournable rassembler les acteurs de
la nation sportive
mais aussi inviter en pratique tous les
Françaises et les Français à faire plus
de sport autour d'un marqueur que sera
les 30 minutes d'activité physique
quotidienne dans lesquelles chacun
pourra se retrouver à son rythme selon
ses envies pour mieux lutter contre la
sédentarité et promouvoir à tout âge de
la vie des modes de vie plus sain en
conclusion mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs je dirais que loin d'être
une parenthèse comme parfois certains le
craignent les jeux vont au contraire
être un levier de transformation durable
de la place du sport dans notre société
et nous ferons en sorte également
d'étaufer dans les mois à venir nos
politiques d'héritage et d'inscrire
l'ensemble de notre nation dans un élan
non seulement plus sportif mais aussi
plus solidaire et plus fraternel à
travers le sport monsieur le président
Président Monsieur le Rapporteur spécial
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
vous remercie pour votre écoute et me
tiens maintenant à votre disposition
pour répondre à vos questions merci
Madame la Ministre alors les deux
premières séries de questions vont être
posées par Jean-Jacques loszac notre
rapporteur udgetire et puis Michel Savin
le président du groupe d'études bien
merci monsieur le Président merci madame
la ministre pour cette présentation très
très détaillée donc nous évoquons
aujourd'hui bien sûr le budget
d'une année tout à fait particulière
puisque c'est l'année des des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques de de 2024
et sur ce plan-là bien sûr nous sommes
toujours très attentif aux observations
de la Cour des comptes même si à ce
stade semble-t-il il n'y a pas de
d'alerte particulière étant donné les
deux filets de sécurité qui existent en
terme de financement des des jobs
c'est-à-dire la la réserve pour ala
d'une part et d'autre part la la la
garantie de de l'État quant à la baisse
des financements du programme 200 119
161 millions d'euros effectivement nous
comprenons très bien que c'est justifié
par le le timing je dirais du règlement
financier des chantiers pilotés par la
solideo financement intervenant en 2022
et 2023 non ce qui nous inquiète sur le
plan strictement budgétaire j'ai envie
de dire c'est c'est l'après 2024 au
regard de la loi de programmation des
finances publiques qui nous conduit
jusqu'en 2025 et surtout quand on fait
le rapprochement de cette loi de
programmation avec les 170 objectifs
stratégique de l'héritage
olympique faire de la France l'un nation
sportive nécessitera à l'évidence une
inflexion de la trajectoire budgétaire
telle qu'elle est envisagée aujourd'hui
pour l'après
2024 un sujet d'actualité maintenant
puisque que ça a été évoqué il y a y a
quelques jours par le Président de la
République c'est ce plan en faveur de
l'insertion professionnelle par le sport
hein pourriez-vous détailler le le
calendrier budgétaire les modalités de
mise en œuvre de ce plan et quels sont
les crédits affecté dans le cadre du PLF
2024 s'agit-il d'augmenter le nombre
d'éducateurs sportifs ou de former déjà
ceux qui sont en place afin qu'ils
disposent en quelque sorte d'une double
compétence et comment les collectivités
locales sont-elles associées au
déploiement de de ce
plan sur un autre sujet qui rejoint la
question de de l'éthique votre ministère
bénéficie en en 2023 à bénéficier pardon
de de 20 équivalent de 20 etutp
supplémentaires on va passé à 36
supplémentaires en 2024 pour renforcer
les dragesses les CF déconcentrés pour
lutter contre les formes de
radicalisation pour la lutte contre les
violences sexuelles et sexistes et
cetera à ce sujet le Sénat avait adopté
au mois de juin dernier une PPL visant à
renforcer la protection des mineurs et
l'honorabilité dans le sport l'Assemblée
nationale d'ailleurs a lancé une
commission d'enquête parlementaire qui
évoque notamment ce sujet peut-on faire
un premier bilan du renforcement des
contrôles et j'ai envie de dire dire
quel est l'avenir du texte voté au Sénat
s'agissant maintenant des des jobes bien
évidemment la question de de
sécurité est tout à fait importante et
le relèvement récent du risque
terroriste constitue un défi
supplémentairire la Cour des comptes a
mis en évidence une insuffisance des
capacités de sécurité privée qui ne
suffirait pas à répondre aux besoins et
le recours aux forces de sécurité
intérieure sera renforcé alors le sujet
est vaste bien sû puisqu'il faut non
seulement sécuriser les compétitions
mais aussi les cérémonies d'ouverture le
parcours de la flamme les événements
organisés en marge et cetera et cetera
alors ce sujet est on est bien d'accord
piloté par ministère de l'intérieur mais
pez-vous nous préciser les les besoins
et nous indiquer quand le dispositif
sera définitivement arrêté alors je ne
reviens pas sur le sport à l'école ou
sur le déplafonnement des taxes habituel
si j'ai envie de dire parce que c'est un
sujet récurrent je terminerai par un
sujet vraiment d'une actualité brûlante
et qui fait quand même assez polémique
ce sont les conditions de l'installation
en France de tout un ensemble de
fédérations sportive internationale on
parle de l'abandement FIFA mais ça
concerne pas simplement la FIFA mais une
trentaine de fédérations internationales
reconnues par le
CIO avec donc pas pas d'impôt sur les
sociétés pas de CFE pas de CVAE des
salariés exonérés de l'impôt sur le
revenu pendant auou moins 5 ans et
cetera ne croyez pas que l'on va d'ors
et déjà très loin pour ne pas dire trop
loin en ce qui concerne les conditions
financières et fiscales d'accueil pour
un certain nombre de fédérations
sportives international qui pour
certaines il faut jamais généraliser qui
pour certaines n'ont pas fait preuve
d'une grande exemplarité ces dernières
décennie en matière de de transparence
ou en matière d'intégrité merci Michel
Savin merci président écoutez moi je
vais essayer de de de de flécher mon
intervention sur quatre sujets et avec
quatre questions bien précises le
premier concerne et vous le savez
plusieurs fois on a abordé ce sujet et
quand concerne les collectivités locales
vous avez
rappelé les montants qui sont affectés
au notamment aux équipements
structurants je je pense et je continue
à avenser lorsqu'on écoute les élus qu'
a un vrai problème aujourd'hui qui
concerne les piscines dans les années 60
l'État avait engagé un ambi plan hein
des 1000 piscines en 4 ans pour doubler
le nombre de bassins dans l'Hexagone
aujourd'hui plus de 70 % des des centres
date d'avant 95 des près de 600 piscines
serai vettus le Syndicat national de
l'éducation physique dénonce des
fermetures de piscine au détriment des
élèves et du savoir nager donc c'est une
vraie question de santé publique
êtes-vous prête madame la ministre à
soutenir un véritable plan Marshal pour
la rénovation et la construction de
piscine et avec à quelle hauteur avec
quels moyen deuxième sujet qui sur
lequel je voulais vous interroger le
mais qui a fait aussi le sujet d'une
question d'actualité tout à l'heure le
second point que je souhaite évoquer
c'est la place de plus en plus
importante de l'islamisme dans le sport
le sport en France est impacté
directement et indirectement par
l'islamisme 65000 pratiquants
s'entraîneraient au sein d'association
sportive communautarisé CQ clubs
seulement ont été identifiés comme
séparatistes sur les 127 qui ont
été recensés cinq ont été fermés quelle
mesure urgent pensez-vous mettre en
place face à ces club qui ne respectent
pas la loi sur la laïité
3è sujet le président en a parlé les 30
minutes d'activité sportives dans
l'école cette demi-heure vous l'avez
précisé madame la ministre entant
d'abord à lutter contre le surpoids et
l'obésité devenu des problèmes de santé
publique depuis de nombreuses années à
contrarot de votre présentation moi j'ai
pas les les mêmes chiffres sur le nombre
d'écoles qui pratiquent qui font
appliquer ces 30 minutes lorsqu'on
interroge les enseignants aujourd'hui
les directeur d'école très peu
aujourd'hui nous répondent qu'il mettent
en place ses 30 minutes journalières
alors où autrement c'est au détriment
des activités physiques et sportives ce
qui n'est pas non plus l'objectif donc
on voit bien que cette politique
d'activité trouve difficilement sa place
dans un programme scolaire qui est déà
très chargé quel bilan chiffré de
l'élargissement du dispositif et quelles
mesures prendre pour généraliser ce
dispositif sans bienure remettre en
cause les heurs de PS enfin dernière
question sur le montant des tasses
affecté alors moi j'y reviens c'est vrai
que c'est un un combat récurrent au
Sénat mais je rappelle quand même que
chaque année l'état reverse
intégralement sur 100 % les taxes
prélevées sur les jeux du patrimoine au
profit la Fondation du Patrimoine 100 %
des taxes qui sont prélevés sont
reversés ce qui est très bien concernant
le sport la part qui revient à l'Agence
nationale du sport sur les paris sportif
c'est seulement 19 %. donc seriez-vous
prête madame est favorable madame la
ministre à soutenir un amendement du
Sénat qui permettrait d'augmenter de 19
au moins à 33 % 1/3 euh de ces revenus
en direction de l'agence nationale du
sport et puis pour flécher bien sûr les
équipements structurants dans une
logique où le sport finance le sport 33
% ça ferait un/3 quand même pour la
politique sportive et 2 ti3 pour le
budget général je pense que c'est un
effort qui mériterait d'être fait en
direction des collectivités qui
attendent beaucoup d'un soutien de
l'État sur ces équipements structurant
madame la ministre je vous laisser
répondre à ces deux premièr
série
merci monsieur le
Président je vais démarrer par la
question de Jean-Jacques losac relatif
relative au moyen terme et notamment à
la
contraction des crédit qui apparaît dans
la loi de programmation des finances
publiques pour le sport entre 2024 et
2025 à hauteur de 130 millions
d'euros pour faire par rapport à ça
tris points d'abord expliquer que
derrière ces 130 millions d'euros de
contraction figure l'effet
mécanique pour 50 millions d'euros de
mesures ponctuelles liées aux Jeux
olympiques et à la grande cause qui
correspondent à notre exercice 2024 je
pense aux primes pour les médaillés à
auteur de 18 millions d'euros 18,6 je
pense au dispositif spécifique en France
tous ces services ses équipements
spécifiques ces éléments d'animation
l'application mobile tout ça mis en
place pour les athlètes pour leur
permettre de performer le mieux possible
à l'été
2024 les besoins exceptionnels
logistique transport hébergement pour
les délégations françaises pendant les
jeux à hauteur de 5,4 millions d'euros
la billetterie populaire à hauteur de
5,5 millions d'euros dans ce budget
l'animation territoriale des jeux 4
millions d'euros si je mets l'ensemble
de ces mesures c'est déjà 40 millions
d'euros qui correspondent à des besoins
pour l'année 2024 et qui donc ne se
retrouvent pas en 2025 même chose pour
la grande cause qui est daté dans le
temps sur l'exercice 2024 donc 10
millions d'euros de moins là-dessus
mécaniquement en
2025 40 + 10 correspondent aux 50 que
j'évoquais il y a un deuxième effet qui
est à hauteur de 80 millions d'euros sur
les crédits de paiement afférant au plan
génération 2024 sur les équipements
sportifs qui correspond à un rythme de
décaissement qui pourrait être plus long
sur ce nouveau plan puisqu'il prévoit
pour 50 % des crédits pluriannuels sur
la construction ou la rénovation des
équipements par définition comme il y a
notamment une tranche sur les
équipements structurants ces chantiers
vont être plus lourd plus long à mener à
bien et donc des décaissements plus
étalés dans le temps et ça n'est qu'un
effet purement comptable l'enveloppe de
300 millions d'euros elle est bien gagée
sur les 3 années en autorisation
d'engagement donc 50 millions d'euros 80
millions d'euros là sur les crédits de
playment du du du plan équipement font
cet écart de 130 millions d'euros et à
l'inverse et c'est mon 3è et dernier
point il y a beaucoup d'éléments dans ce
budget qui eux correspondent à des
engagements dans la durée je pense
évidemment à ce que je viens d'évoquer
sur le plan génération 2024 mais je
pense aussi aux effectifs
supplémentaires les 36 ETP
supplémentaires qui font suite au vin de
l'an dernier dans les services
déconcentrés qui sont là à impact
durable je pense aussi à la stabilité
des effectifs des conseillers techniques
sportifs dans les fédérations je pense
aussi à la généralisation que j'ai
évoqué des 2 heures de sport en plus
pour les collégiens cranté par le
Président de la République puisqu'il a
dit sa volonté de voir ce dispositif se
généraliser à l'horizon de 2026 et il en
va de même du passeport dont on est
aujourd'hui sur une mécanique non
démentie année après année d'extension
des publics bénéficiaires et des
structures
éligibles donc on sera de la même
manière qu'on a été très à la tâche pour
obtenir des crédits sans précédent sur
cet exercice 24 sur cette même volonté
de continuer à ancrer la construction de
notre nation sportive au-delà des jeux
au-delà de la grande cause et j'ajoute
que la perspective peut-être
d'accueillir en France les jeux
olympique et paralympique divers en 2030
nourriront là aussi cette ambition sans
oublier la cinquantaine de gésis que
j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure à l'horizon
de 2027 qui sont d'ors et déjà et
bénéficiaire de subvention de la part du
ministère des Sports pour les années à
venir sur le sujet de l'insertion par le
sport thématique au combien prioritaire
à forceorie dans le contexte que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui nous avons eu
trois temps d'action un premier temps à
Drancy consistant à prendre l'engagement
avec Olivier du sopt et Carole Grandjean
de passer de 20 à 100000 20000 à 100000
le nombre des bénéficiaires de nos
dispositifs d'insertion par le sport
contrat d'engagement jeune pic 100 %
inclusion dispositif du sésam service
civique dans le sport et cetera nous
avons en juin dernier fait un Grenel des
métiers du sport dans lequel nous avons
notamment pris l'engagement là aussi
avec Olivier du sopte de remédier au
maquis actuel des 1000 formations
diplômantes qui p perdent les jeunes
quand ils veulent rentrer dans nos
métiers du sport ils ne savent plus par
quel périmètre le faire il y a des
redondances des recoupements nous avons
pris l'engagement de simplifier cette
architecture et de rendre beaucoup plus
lisible sur une plateforme dédiée à
l'élaboration de laquelle mon ministère
travaille aujourd'hui avec le ministère
du
Travail qui nous permettra de très bien
cartographier non seulement les
formations diplômantes mais également
les offres d'emplois disponible dans le
secteur avec l'engagement qui a été
rappelé par le Président de la
République lundi matin à l'Élysée de
multiplier là aussi par 5 c'est-à-dire
atteindre le seuil de 100000 emplois
créés dans ou par le sport à l'horizon
de la fin du quinquena en
2027 et le dernier étage qui est celui
qu'a annoncé qu'a porté le président de
la République lundi matin en présence de
l'ensemble des associations d'insertion
par le sport c'est de créer en effet
c'estes profils des 1000 éducateurs
sociau sportifs dans autant de clubs dit
club engagés en faveur de l'insertion et
de l'inclusion par le sport à travers
environ 500 géographies nous affinerons
là-dessus les annonces autour de la
première ministre vendredi matin à
l'occasion du comité interministériel à
la ville et cette démarche là s'inscrira
plus globalement dans la volonté que
nous avons d'embarquer 10000 clubs
aujourd'hui partout en France dans une
vraie logique d'affirmation de leur rôle
social et sociétal pour les postes
d'éducateurs que nous avons évoqué les
1000 c'est une enveloppe de 20000 € par
emploi pendant 3 ans qui sera mobilisé
c'est donc au total sur ces 3 années à
venir des financements de l'ordre de 60
millions d'euros qui seront mobilisés
1000 emplois 20000 € par emploi pendant
ans sur le sujet de la sécurité sujet au
combien important Gérald d'Anin a d'ors
et déjà calibré les forces de sécurité
intérieure qu'il mobilisera pour la
cérémonie d'ouverture 45000 et en
moyenne sur chacun des jours de la
période olympique et paralympique 30000
en
moyenne nous aurons en complément de ces
forces de sécurité intérieure le recours
en moyenne à à peu près 17000 agents de
sécurité privé au quotidien avec des
pics jusqu'à 22000 et vous avez raison
de souligner que sur cet enjeu nous
avons besoin de continuer notre effort
pour que on arrive non seulement à
former encore plus de personnes à ces
métiers de la sécurité privée il y a
aujourd'hui une action résolue qui est
menée en ce sens sous la haette du
préfet de la région Île-de-France avec
Pôle emploi qui a déjà permis de faire
6000 recrutement 7000 entrées en
formation plus 1000 entrées en formation
d'étudiants sur le nouveau certificat de
qualification professionnelle le titre
de sécurité événementielle mis en place
spécifiquement par l'État nous avançons
bien mais il faut qu'on accélère encore
sur l'apparimement
entre les marchés du COJO attribué à une
à un certain nombre d'entreprises de
sécurité privée et ces personnes que
nous formons ou bien que nous recrutons
de manière à ce que on s'assure que
chacune des entreprises attributaaires
des lots de sécurité privée du cojot et
bien un plan de gestion de des effectif
qui nous permettra d'être totalement au
rendez-vous de nos objectifs nous sommes
à la tâche nous avançons bien de manière
très unie avec le ministère de
l'intérieur avec le ministère du Travail
avec le cojot et avec la volonté
d'atteindre nos objectifs la question du
recours aux forces armées ne se posant
pas pour le moment je l'ai dit à
plusieurs reprises c'est une question
qui n'est pas tabou mais aujourd'hui
nous sommes et au moins jusqu'au début
de l'année 2024 dans une démarche
consistant à prioriser tous les efforts
que nous avons à fournir sur le champ de
la sécurité
privée s'agissant du dispositif FIFA je
voudrais vraiment insister sur
sur un point vous savez souvent j'ai dû
me battre pour que le
sport
accède à un vrai statut de politique
publique à un vrai statut de voilà
ministère de plein exercice qu'il est
toute sa place dans les dispositifs
prévus pour les autres
ministères nous avons un dispositif qui
a été mis en place pour les
organisations
internationales visant à l'attractivité
de notre fiscalité
moi je me félicite que
enfin les fédérations sportives
internationales et donc le sport donc
l'influence de la France dans le sport
mondial puisse émerarger à leur tour à
ces dispositifs ce qui n'était pas le
cas précédemment parce que ces
dispositifs étaient ouverts à des
organisations internationales composé
d'État et non pas de fédération
internationale j'ajoute que le besoin
d'avoir la conception d'un régime fiscal
à la fois attractif et proportionné
s'appliquant aux fédérations sportives
international figurait dans les
recommandations d'un certain nombre de
parlementaires de tout bord y compris du
groupe écologiste avec Hubert Julien
Laferrière deux parlementaires de la
majorité et que le besoin est de longue
date identifié on on peut pas plaider
qu'il faut améliorer et renforcer la
diplomatie sportive à l'échelle
internationale et ne pas s'en donner la
capacité pour autant je le redis ce
régime est extrêmement proportionné
d'abord je veux souligner que les
activités qui vont pouvoir bénéficier
d'exonération d'impôt au niveau des
structures elles sont strictement limité
aux seules mission de gouvernance ou de
promotion de la pratique du sport tout
le champ des activités lucratives et
concurrentielles n'est
pas dans le champ de l'exonération
prévue pour le volet
structure et je soulligne que dire qu'on
exonère d'impôt les structures c'était
déjà quelque chose et sur ce champ
encore une fois uniquement des missions
de gouvernance ou de promotion de la
pratique du sport c'était déjà reconnu
par l'administration fiscale donc que
vient faire la loi pas accorder un
cadeau nouveau elle vient simplement
sécuriser une interprétation qui était
déjà reconnu connu par l'administration
fiscale et je le redis dès lors qu'une
Fédée sportive internationale
installerait en France des activités de
nature commerciale par exemple
l'organisation de compétition par
exemple la session des droits associés
elle serait pour le coup bien sûr
soumise à l'impôt commercial dans les
conditions de droit commun et j'ajoute
que du côté des salarié l'exonération
d'impôt qui est prévu sur le revenu là
aussi ne vaut que pour ceux des salariés
qui travaillent dans le champ non
marchand de ces fé des sportives
internationales une personne qui
travaillerait dans le champ de ces
activités concurrentielles serait soumis
à l'impôt sur le revenu et l'exonération
elle est encadrée dans le temps avec une
limitation à 5 ans donc nous avons là je
crois un régime qui est à la fois oui un
supplément d'attractivité et nous le
recherchons nous l'assumons et en même
temps quelque chose qui était déjà très
largement reconnu par l'administr
fiscale et surtout qui est strictement
proportionné à l'objectif
poursuivi s'agissant des piscines je
crois que en effet dans les dernières
années nous n'avons pas pu suffisamment
investir dans notre parc de piscine et
je pense que l'une des raisons à cela
c'est qu'il y avait déjà une énorme
facture énergétique à l'entretien du
parc
existant on l'a vu avec tout ce qu'il a
été nécessaire de faire dans le cadre du
plan de relance avec l'augmentation des
coûts de l'énergie la facture qui s'est
tout de suite Alourd pour les
collectivités et les gestionnaires
privés d'infrastructures d'où la
création du fond vert et la volonté que
nous avons eu de le consacrer à
l'accompagnement d'un certain nombre de
travaux de rénovation thermique
énergétique des équipements objectif
auquel nous avons aussi concouru à
travers le plan de sobriéé énergétique
est un vrai succès du fait de la
mobilisation collective des acteurs du
sport aujourd'hui le plan génération
2024 va nous permettre de faire plus on
avait un socle par lequel
l'ANS faisait un investissement de
l'ordre de 25 à 30 millions d'euros par
an dans les équipements structurants pas
que les piscines l'ensemble des
équipements structurants ce socle nous
le préservons et en plus nous y AJ
une tranche de 150 millions d'euros
c'est-à-dire la moitié du plan
génération équipement 2024 génération
2024 pour nous permettre de
financer la rénovation ou la
construction d'à peu près 500
équipements structurants et de pouvoir
aider chacun de ces projets à hauteur de
300000 € de manière à ce que l'aide soit
substantielle et qu'elle puisse générer
l'effet de levier attendu pour les
collectivités locales comme on a pu le
constater dans le cadre du plan sur les
terrains de proximité il est important
pour chacun de ces investissements
d'avoir une capacité d'investissement
suffisant et je soulligne que ce plan à
la différence du plan 5000 portera pas
seulement sur la construction de
nouveaux équipements mais il embarque
bien la dimension rénovation et ça
c'était très
important sur le sujet de la laïcité
vous savez à quel point je suis attaché
à la plus grande des fermetés sur le
respect de ce
principe je l'ai dit la
laïcité dans le sport c'est trois choses
c'est d'abord
réaffirmer notre attachement le plus
strict et le plus absolu à la neutralité
totale des équipes de France d'où les
éléments de clarification que j'ai
apporté sur le nom par du voile par nos
délégations j'ai redit également que je
saluais la décision du Conseil d'État
qui a
rappelé qu'il y avait bien sûr la
liberté de conscience pour les usagers
mais qu'il y avait la faculté de la
restreindre et notamment de restreindre
le port de signes religieux le temps et
sur le lieu des
compétitions c'est ce que le football
fait c'est ce que le basket fait et
c'est ce que chacune de nos fédérations
aujourd'hui dans l'exercice de son
pouvoir règlementaire peut faire si
besoin avec avec notre accompagnement
ils savent que notre main là-dessus est
tendue et en même temps il faut rappeler
que la liberté de conscience c'est aussi
de pouvoir porter le voile lorsque l'on
est dans un cadre d'entraînement
lorsqu'on est dans une vie de sportif de
tous les jours et qu'il ne s'agit pas du
temps et du lieu des compétitions au
terme des statuts de ces fédérations qui
ont choisi de restreindre le port du
voile le dernier élément de ce
dispositif c'est
évidemment la lutte résolue contre
toutes les formes de prosélitisme et
contre toutes les formes de dérives
séparatistes communautariste voire de
radicalisation dans le sport et là je
veux vous redire mon action résolue en
la matière
3449 contrôles effectués en 2022 dont 27
ont donné lieu au repérage de signaux
faibles de
séparatisme c'est 0,8 % c'est toujours
0,8 % de trop je le disais tout à
l'heure et il faut bien sûr continuer
l'effort pour prévenir la survenance de
nouveaux flux mais ramenons à sa juste
proportion le phénomène tel qu'il se
présente
aujourd'hui par rapport à ça par rapport
à cette prévention et cette action
résolue 117 référents prévention de la
radicalisation on été mis en place dans
les drages et les sdgs 23 référents
éthiqu et intégrité ont été déployés
dans les fédérations dans les
établissements pardon 39 référents dans
les fédération à qui j'ai demandé de
renforcer leurs moyens sur ces sujets-là
160 agents de mes services déconcentrés
ont été formé sur le respect du contrat
d'engagement républicain et on continue
on aura l'an prochain 6000
établissements qui seront contrôlés un
programme inédit de la même manière que
j'ai engagé un certain nombre de
fédérations prioritaires 11 d'entre
elles dans un processus de
conventionnement avec le Conseil
interministériel de prévention la
délinquence et de la radicalisation et
j'ajoute que tout ça c'est assis sur des
moyens renforcés les plus 20 effectifs
que j'évoqué sur 2023 et les plus
36 qui sont prévus dans ce budget pour
nous permettre d'étauffer et d'accélérer
l'action du ministère je ne lâcherai
rien sur ces sujets-là c'est des sujets
trop importants et je suis trop attaché
à la qualité du vivre ensemble dans le
sport pour laisser cours à ces dérives
séparatistes sur le troisième sujet qui
est celui des 30 minutes d'activité
physique quotidienne ça vient bien en
complément de l'éducation physique et
sportive le PS restant le socle de
l'enseignement du sport dans notre pays
oui il faut aller chercher les 15 à 20 %
d'établissements supplémentaires qui
aujourd'hui n'ont pas encore réalisé la
généralisation nous sommes parfaitement
lucides là-dessus avec Gabriel Atal pour
ça nous animons beaucoup plus fortement
les les référents 30 minutes d'apq dans
les territoires nous avons mobilisé les
recteurs sur cet objectifs prioritaire
nous avons aussi rappelé l'importance de
s'appuyer sur l'équipe de France des
athlètes l'équipe de France des 30
minutes d'activité plus de 150 d'entre
eux qui nous ont donné leur accord pour
aller dans les établissements scolaires
et aider les professeurs des écoles à
faire faire ces 30 minutes et à
apprendre les bons gestes aux enfants et
j'ajoute que d'ici la fin de l'année
2023 nous aurons fini de livrer tous les
kits dans toutes les écoles primaires
qui vont permettre de doter les écoles
de cersceau de plot de chasubl qui sont
un petit supplément pour les professeurs
des écoles
lorsqu'ils développent cette démarche de
connexion du corps et de l'esprit qui
est si essentiel pour les petits dans
notre nation et sur le 4e élément qui
est
les taxes affectées je sais là-dessus
que c'est un point de vigilance de
longue date de la part du Sénat et je
l'en remercie de veiller toujours à ce
que le sport et les moyens dont il a
besoin je voudrais souligner là-dessus
que la progression des crédit budgétaire
alloué à mon ministère si je regarde la
période qui va de 2020 à 2024 elle a été
de 350 millions d'euros dans le même
temps l'augmentation du rendement des
trois taxes affecté n'a été que de plus
67 millions d'euros ce que je veux dire
c'est que la dynamique des crédits
budgétaires a été très supérieure à
celle des taxes affectées et donc nous
sommes aujourd'hui dans une logique où
nous n'avons pas été pénalisés par
l'évolution du rendement de ces tax et
par la mécanique du plafonnement et je
le dis très net aujourd'hui tous les
arbitrages que j'ai sollicité pour ce
budget de manière à construire étape par
étape brique par brique notre nation
sportive je les ai
obtenu et donc je ne suis pas dans une
situation aujourd'hui à devoir priver le
budget général de certains suppléments
de ressources
pour financer les politiques non mais je
je je le dis vous savez quand j'ai
besoin d'argent en plus je suis la
première à taper du point sur la table
systématiquement pour le faire ce que je
pense en revanche et là où je vous
rejoins pour la suite c'est qu'il y a
pour moi un principe très important qui
a été poursuivi avec la taxe buffet et
qui doit l'être également avec la taxe
sur les paris sportifs qui est ce
principe que le sport finance le sport
et que nous avons donc là une capacité à
aller chercher des réserves de crédit
supplémentaire pour l'avenir et je
n'écarte pas du tout la discussion pour
l'avenir sur ces enjeux je considère que
sur cet exercice 2024 cont tenu des
financements inédits allouer aux Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques nous avons
tout ce qu'il faut pour faire un très
bon travail sur cet exercice
2024 merci on va continuer je vais
prendre toutes vos questions en
commençant par Claude KNE qui est donc
rapporteur de la mission d'information
sur les Jeux Olympiques et
parallympiques merci monsieur le
Président Madame Mame la ministre merci
pour votre présentation nous sommes
effectivement en année olympique et sans
surprise une par conséquent du budget
sera lié directement ou indirectement au
goop je ne vais pas redétailler les
différents dispositifs que vous nous
avez présenté sur le volet haut de
performance les primes pour les médaillé
le dispositif gagné en France et cetera
et cetera mais ma première question est
est-ce que ce coup de pouce suffira à
atteindre l'objectif du top 5 des
médailles assignées par le Président de
la République aux délégations tricolore
si l'engagement sur ces questions est
essentiel pour tenir la promesse du
succès de ces jeux en permettant de
faire rayonner la France la notion
d'héritage que vous avez évoqué non
seulement en terme d'infrastructure mais
aussi surtout en matière
d'accompagnement de la pratique sportive
et d'insertion par le sport les tout
autant et vous l'avez dit ces jeux
auront une place durable dans notre
société alors euh j'ai quand même une
petite inquiétude euh alors que les
puisque les trajectoires budgétaires qui
sont inscrites dans ce PLF laissent
apparaître une baisse de 160 millions
d'euros pour le sport des 2025
euh la question de ne pas manquer ce
rendez-vous d'une grande nation sportive
et donc particulièrement
d'actualité pour ce budget cette grande
cause nationale ne sera dotée lui que de
10,5 millions d'euros dont la moitié
sera consacré à des campagnes de
communication alors à grande cause petit
moyen comment comptez-vous dès lors
dynamiser votre politique et envisager
les financements nécessaires à ce réel
challenge car personne ne comprendrait
que le budget du ministère des Sports
puisse baisser suite aux Jeux Olympiques
lui qui pèse à peine 02 % du budget de
l'État pouvez-vous vous engager et lever
les doutes à ce
sujet nous sommes donc arrivés à ce
rendez-vous et je souhaiterais également
que vous positionnier sans équivoque sur
plusieurs questions vous l'avez fait sur
le déplafonnement des taxes affectées
donc je ne vais pas y revenir par contre
comment comptez-vous aborder ce qui fait
la force de notre modèle c'est-à-dire
garder un tissu associatif et local très
solide élaborer des politiques
cohérentes en renforçant la transparence
et en garantissant l'équité l'accès au
financement comment trouver un équilibre
pour financer à la fois des équipements
de proximité mais également des
installation structurante attractive et
de qualité à ce sujet quel est l'état de
vos réflexions concernant une balance
entre acteurs public et acteurs privés
permettant de préserver une politique
sportive solide enfin et c'est ma
dernière question ce qui concerne
l'Agence nationale du sport nous savons
que son volet territorial doit être
dynamiser suite aux critiques de la Cour
des comptes comment abordez-vous cette
problématique président caner
oui monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre un commentaire et trois
questions rapides dans le temps qui nous
est imparti qui n'est pas de 44 secondes
ah voilà
je je pensais être censuré avant même de
de commencer prendre la parole
commentaire sur la la la gération où
l'amendement abusivement appelé FIFA
j'ai entendu vos
explications il ne reste pas moins vrai
madame la ministre que quand on pose des
questions d'actualité comme tout à
l'heure vous étiez présente à la séance
des QAG en se demandant comment trouver
20 millions d'euros pour boucler le
programme territoire zéro
chômeurs permettre des exonérations
fiscales pour la FIFA qui je crois
budget de 7 milliards d'euros et des
excédents de 4 milliards d'euros ça me
paraît un petit peu compliqué à
expliquer euh à nos concitoyens donc je
reste extrêmement euh nous restons pour
notre groupe très réservé sur cet
amendement nous aurons l'occasion bien
sûr d'y revenir pendant le PLF dans les
questions euh j'ai entendu votre
explication sur la baisse euh des
crédits du programme sport qui va être
autour de 127 millions entre 2024 et et
2025 vous l'expliquez pour des raisons
mécaniques mais naurit on pas dû
profiter de cette opportunité euh
budgétaire pour lancer peut-être de
nouveaux programmes par exemple un grand
plan Marshal pour les équipements
sportifs dans les universités qui en ont
bien besoin donc euh est-ce que vous
comptez peut-être encore mieux négocier
comme vous le faites aujourd'hui je n'en
doute pas un seul instant avec by et je
sais ce que ça veut dire euh pour
développer et profiter du gain que vous
avez reçu euh que nous avons
collectivement reçu pour le lancement
des des J et garder donc cette avance
pour lancer de nouveaux programmes euh
une question précise sur l'avenir du
Stade de France qui va faire l'objet
d'une grande rénovation nous le savons
pour accueillir les les
JO question sur votre stratégie en la
matière puisque manifestement il y a
deux options qui potentiellement peuvent
s'opposer à savoir la vente du Stade de
France ou dégager un nouveau consortium
pour la gestion à partir de l'été
2025 dire est-ce que vous nous confirmer
qu'il y a bien là deux options en
concurrence et quelle est la priorité
qui est celle du ministère en la matière
et enfit une question plus qui pourrait
paraître plus anecdotique mais qui n'est
pas neutre c'est le le chantier du
village des athlètes que j'ai eu
l'occasion de visiter il y a une semaine
avec des membres de mon
groupe les choses vont dans le bon sens
manifestement le chantier sera terminé
donc le village opérationnel pour le
moment des Joos même si c'est une course
contre la montre mais il y a eu quand
même un incident entre guillemets
puisqueune centaine de travailleurs sans
papier ont été employés sur les 68
chantiers des Jos de 2024 euh des
procédures au prudom ont été lancées par
ces mêmes salariés sans faire de lien
avec le sujet qui nous attend dans
quelques jours concernant la loi
immigration euh il y avait des exigences
d'éthique au travers de la solideo
est-ce que vous avez AZ suivi ce dossier
comment vous la
l'interpréter et comment expliquer
l'emploi de hors de tout cadre de
d'ouvriers sur des chantiers qui sont
financés de manière publique de manière
assez large voilà les questions que je
voulais vous évoquer puis dernière
remarque même si j'ai un peu dépassé mon
temps je m'en excuse
concernant l'objectif des médailles euh
nous pouvons être inquiet avec le
résultat des championnats du monde de
Budapest en matière d'athlétisme quand
même la la matière reine des la
discipline reine des des JO est-ce qu'il
y a notamment dans cette fédération une
prise de conscience liée à la petite
médaille d'argent même si elle est
importante euh que nous avons donc
obtenue à l'occasion de ces championnats
à la fin de ce mois d'août Stéphane
pienoir merci monsieur le Président je
vais essayer de pour ma part de
respecter le temps àarti euh madame la
ministre madame non mais c'est une
pratique courante dans votre groupe donc
n sommes pas étonnés dans cette
commission madame la ministre je vous ai
entendu parler de la nation sportive et
je partage avec vous évidemment à la
fois cette cette belle ambition ce bel
objectif pour notre pays même si ni vous
ni ni personne n'a le pouvoir de de
décréter la réussite de nos athlètes de
nos de nos sportifs français d'une
manière générale et on sait à quel point
c'est un levier puissant pour permettre
pour inciter la pratique du sport dans
notre pays je vais juste m'attarder un
petit instant sur évidemment le le
résultat déceptif he du Mondial de rugby
lequel nous nous nous avions beaucoup
d'espoir des moyens importants ont été
concédés envers la Fédération française
de rugby depuis quelques années en
réalité quel bilan en tirez-vous
aujourd'hui avec le résultat que nous
connaissons que nous connaissons deème
point sur les sur les piscines alors
Michel Savin l'a très bien dit je
rappelle que c'est une obligation fait
par les programmes de
l'Éducation nationale et qui seent en
fait à des à une faisabilité toute
simple he sur le terrain bien sûr il y a
la construction des piscines vous avez
parlé d'un éventuellement d'un il a été
évoqué un plan Marshal la rénovation
parce que ça représente un coûp de
fonctionnement extrêmement important
pour les collectivités locales mais il y
a plus simple en fait il y a juste des
accès au créneau et parfois une un
besoin de de se déplacer de déplacer des
classes et ma ma question c'est quelle
compensation les collectivités locales
peuvent peuvent-ells envisager pour leur
permettre de se déplacer d'avoir accès à
des des créneaux d'éducation on sait que
c'est important notamment pour la la
prévention des noyades trème point je
vous ai entendu parler de 6 millions
supplémentaires sur pour les maisons
sport santé quels sont où en sommes-nous
des dispositifs visant à une meilleure
prise en charge des des prescriptions de
Séan de de sport santé peut-on envisager
par exemple ouverture à des licences
temporaires multisport comme cela peut
se pratiquer
dans mon département de de manéoir à
proximité de de ma commune et puis
dernière chose puisque c'est une
audition budgétaire nous avons tous
entendu le ministre le maire parler
d'effort national pour contribuer au
retraissement des finances publiques
avec nos 3 milliards de dette votre
ministère est-il concerné par cet effort
à court ou moyen terme et si c'est le
cas quels sont les pistes que vous
envisageriez éventuellement je vous
remercie Bernard
Feller
merci monsieur le Président moi aussi je
faire cette compétition
face au chronomètre
pour d'abord saluer la ministre et et me
réjouir effectivement de des des
annonces que vous nous faites sur sur le
plan budgétaire je pense que je vous
souhaite dans ces exercices d'être un
petit peu épargné de tout ce qui vous
était arrivé jusqu'à présent avec la
Fédération française de de foot de de
rugby de handball le cnsof enfin qui
sont malgré tout des marqueurs
importants dans la communication pour le
sport alors que ça devrait être autre
chose moi je reviens sur sur vos vos
annonces et sur le le sport scolaire et
universitaire qui pour moi me paraisse
enfin sont sont essentiels euh j'ai j'ai
bien entendu les les les les projets
quand serez-vous en mesure de revenir et
de nous dire effectivement comment ça se
passe parce que en relation avec
l'Éducation nationale parce qu'on
s'aperçoit que les 30 minutes par jour
moi je plaide depuis 3 ans depuis que je
suis élu pour ces 30 minutes hélas quand
j'interroge les les écoles de mon
territoire c'est quand même pas pas
beaucoup
pratiquer le sport aussi au au au
collège les moyens aussi mis sur le plan
universitaire c'est c'est quand même
quelque chose d'important je trouve moi
je vouslaai je vous l'ai dit je je pense
qu'on devrait faire une promotion et une
publicité plus importante pour les même
pour les champions universitaires parce
que c'est des beaux exemples pour notre
jeunesse bien mieux
que que d'autres champion très
médiatique qui abandonneent toutes
études et qui du coup on part parfois
des comportements ou des déclarations
qui peuvent inquiéter qui sont pas
exemplaires du tout donc quand
pourrez-vous revenir nous dire quel
qu'est-ce qui se passe effectivement
tout dernier point sur la santé aussi le
sport santé on nous annonce aussi
beaucoup de de choses mais dans la
pratique euh ben la pas elle est
annoncer les gens en parlent mais la
mise en place est est pas évidente même
pour les praticiens de santé pour
pouvoir obtenir justement toute cet
apport que peut être l'activité physique
pour améliorer la santé de nos
concitoyens Jérémy
Baky merci monsieur le Président Madame
la Ministre merci pour vos propos et et
vos réponses mes chers collègues passer
à la fin permet d'avoir des questions
plus plus modeste et donc je respecterai
le temps imparti si le chronomètre
repart à zéro oui sinon ça va être
compliqué mes chers collègues donc vous
l'avez dit Madame la Ministre l'année
sportive a été décrétée comme grande
cause nationale 2024 par le Président de
la République avec la volonté je cite de
de créer une grande nation sportive et
je trouve évidemment que ceci est une
bonne chose je vais me concentrer
uniquement sur deux trois questions et
quelques remarques la première je trouve
la la fablesse des crédits en matière de
développement de la pratique sportive
des étudiants seulement 1 million
d'euros lui est consacré alors même que
la association nationale des étudiants
en sciences et techniqu des activités
physiques souligne que seulement 31 %
des étudiants pratiquent une activité
physique dans le cadre de l'Université
ma question est donc de savoir quel
offre sportive ou quel accompagnement
euh vous envisagez avec ces 1 million
d'euros pour massifier je dirais la
pratique sportive des étudiants la
deuxième question c'est sur le nouveau
plan des 5000 terrains de sport qui
visent à répondre euh au développement
des activités physiques et sportives des
jeunes là aussi vous l'avez évoqué un
plan doté 300 millions d'euros sur 3 ans
et ce plan étant de ça puisque la ns
estime à que 60 % des des équipements
soit 180000 d'entre eux sont vitustes
alors ma question c'est de savoir si le
le fond vert prévoyant 2 milliards
d'euros de crédit pour la rénovation
énergétique euh des bâtiments pouvait
être mobilisé au moins en partie
justement à ces objectifs de rénovation
des équipements sportifs et enfin
dernière question pensez-vous que les
moyens
àouer concernant l'héritage des Jeux
olympiques sont suffisants pour réussir
cette grande ambition et participer
ainsi comme le disait le président de la
République à bâtir une grande nation
sportive je vous remercie Mathilde
Olivier merci Madame la Ministre merci
pour cette vision globale de vos
engagements budgétaires sportifs sur
l'année 2024 vous nous avez répondu sur
les exonérations fiscales sur les Instit
institution internationale pourtant à
l'aise financièrement mais donc cela
continue de nous poser questions pour
une bonne lisibilité il doit y avoir
aussi des moyens similaires accordés au
sport amateurs dans les territoires
alors quelle perspective pour le sport
amateur qui reste un ciment du lien
social et de sortie de la
sédentarité dans les
territoires je partage aussi les
inquiétudes sur le souffle budgétaire
invoqué en 2020 que le souffle
budgétaire invoqué en 2024 ne retombe
pour les exercices post
2024 le sport ne peut pas se contenter
d'une seule année de dynamisme financier
et je sais que votre gouvernement en a
fait une priorité alors j'espère que ça
restera euh que ça le restera et donc
quelle garantie vous pouvez nous donner
pour l'après Jeux Olympiques et l'après
2024 et puis aussi revenir sur le Pass
sport euh qui qui va subir je crois une
baisse des crédits par rapport à l'année
passée alors que l'aide n'est
actuellement pas suffisante pour
permettre aux jeunes qui sont ciblés par
ce dispositif d'accéder aux associations
c'est une aide de 50 € alors que souvent
les licences coûtent plutôt autour de
100 150 200 € alors ne pensez-vous pas
que ce Pass est actuellement inadapté au
besoins de nos jeunes adhérents et qu'il
faudrait peut-être soit augmenter les
crédits pour avoir un reste à charge
moins important euh ou plus avoir de de
reste à charge du tout euh peut-être
aussi revenir sur les budgets pour
l'égalité femmes hommes dans le sport et
le financement d'action notamment de la
diffusion de matchs féminins sur les sur
les antennes et une dernière question
qui rejoint celle de d'autres collègues
aussi sur la faiblesse des crédits pour
le sport à l'université quelle piste
envisagez-vous alors que le sport à
l'université reste un élément essentiel
dans la construction des étudiants et
une bouffée d'air en dehors de leurs
cours merci
meric
durx madame la ministre je vous remercie
de de votre présentation j'avais moi
aussi quelques questions quant aux Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques à venir dans
d'utres pays tout d'abord vous annoncé
une prime pour les médaillers des
financements pour des dispositifs comme
gagner en France mais concrètement
comment envisagez-vous l'accompagnement
de notre de nos sportifs athlètes sur le
moyen long terme pour gagner les
modailles que que vous avez évoqué on
souvient tous du cas symbolique d'Émilie
Andéol qui est j de cas médaillé
olympique à Rio qui quelques mois plus
tard tiré la sonette d'alarme sur sa
situation en étant au chômage et dans le
besoin et elle disait même avoir enfin
parfois regretté d'avoir été championne
olympique nous connaissons le modèle
anglais qui salarie à hauteur de 3000 €
ses athlètes surt une durée d'olympiade
sous conditions de performance et de
résultat ce qui leur a permis d'obtenir
65 médailles en 2012 d'être la 3ème
nation la plus performante et d'obtenir
depuis plus de 60 médailles à chaque
olympiade bien loin de nous
malheureusement je rappelle que même le
président Macron à l'issue des Jeux
Olympiques à Tokyo c'était un petit peu
étonné avait été déçu de de notre de nos
résultats dont il est aussi quelque part
comptable au regard de de de crédit
qu'il souhaite donner à notre à notre
sport donc Madame la Ministre comment
pouvez-vous faire adopter un véritable
contrat sportif de haut niveau qui
permettrait d'avoir des résultats plus
en rapport avec le statut de la France
deuxièmement madame la ministre c'est
une question quant à à l'héritage à la
fois sportif et culturel une question
que j'ai déjà posé à votre collègue
ministre de la Culture hier pourquoi pas
imaginer pour célébrer cet héritage
sportif un musée de l'olympisme à Paris
il y avait des projets notamment dans la
gerre de saint-is pleel mais l'État n'a
pas soutenu l'initiative je pas vous
rappeler l'héritage très important et la
place qu' a la France dans le renouveau
de l'olympisme dans le sport en général
dans les fédérations international donc
il y a pas vraiment de grand musées du
sport en France ça pourrait être
l'occasion et aussi pour valoriser notre
candidature en 2030 d'en créer un à
l'issue et puis enfin une dernière
question euh je reviens sur ce ce
problème très important de l'islamisme
qui gangrinene notre société et le sport
en particulier vous n'avez pas vraiment
répondu à ce qu'a dit mon collègue sur
si j'ai bien compris les 122 euh clubs
identifiés identifiés ça veut dire qu'il
y en a peut-être d'autres qui dans
lesquelles il y a des pratiques
séparatistes islamistes très très
dangereuses vous vous en avez fermé cinq
et ma question est simple qu'est-ce que
vous attendez pour fermer les 122 autres
voilà
Anne vantalon
oui merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre je souhaite revenir sur le
savoir nager et vous interroger sur la
pénuie des maîtres nageurs sauveteurs
alors la Fédération Française de
Natation estime à 5000 le nombre de
postes vacants autant de professionnels
qui manquent pour la sécurité des
beigneurs mais également pour
l'enseignement de la natation la pénurie
s'aggrave pendant que le nombre de
noyades augmente et les collectivités
connaissent des difficultés de
recrutement et de emplacement sur tous
les types de postes liés aux activités
aquatiques nous l'avons malheureusement
constaté l'été dernier avec la fermeture
certains jours de piscine municipal
alors une fois recruté reste le problème
de la fidélisation des maîtres nageurs
et l'été 2024 fait craindre aux
collectivités des difficultés encore
plus grandes pour la surveillance de la
médiade du fait de la mobilisation des
CRS mns pour les Jeux Olympiques alors
les états généraux de l'encadrement et
de la surveillance dans la filière
aquatique ont été organisé le 10 février
dernier et ont permis d'échanger
d'avancer notamment sur les évolutions
réglementaires l'accès aux formations ou
encore le nombre de certifications
permettant d'obtenir le titre de mns
alors à cette occasion vous aviez
annoncé une grande le lancement d'une
grande campagne de communication et de
promotion pour encourager l'évocation en
amont de la saison estivale donc quel
bilan pouvez-vous nous faire de cette
campagne de promotion et de
communication quelles mesures concrètes
découle en découle pour que faute de
maître nageurs les piscines ne reste pas
fermé et que le savoir nager soit
encouragé je vous remercie David
Ros merci monsieur le Président al
madame laamise vu le grand nombre de
questions déjà posées par mes collègues
puisque en sport on joue collectif je
poserai que deux questions mais je
voudrais au préalable faire un certain
nombre de remarques d'abord pour
publiquement vous FA F cité pour la
détermination dont vous avez fait preuve
face à la Fédération française de
football de rugby et aussi de patinage
c'est même si elles sont indépendantes
c'est important qu'il a un message clair
et fort des autorités publiques par
ailleurs contrairement à mon à mon
collègue Piednoir je considère que la
Coupe du monde de rugby a été un succès
un succès populaire un succès en terme
de sécurité et je le dis aussi un succès
sportif parce que perdre avec évidemment
la déception que ça peut représenter de
un point face à l'Afrique du Sud qui
elle-même avait perdu en poule de de
points face à l'Irlande qui elle-même a
perdu de deux points face à la
Nouvelle-Zélande que nous avons
nous-même battu fait que en fait pour
moi l'essentiel c'est pas de participer
l'essentiel c'est pas de gagner mais
c'est de participer pour gagner et c'est
ce qu'a fait l'équipe de France de rugby
elle gagnera d'autres coupes du monde on
est maintenant dans le top 4 et ce
serait très prétentieux dans le sport de
haut niveau d'annoncer à l'avance qu'on
va gagner toutes les compétitions
internationales alors plus globalement
j'ai entendu vos réponses sur le la
question liée au taxes et au
plafonnement et aux piscines alors je
vais lier les deux parce que je rejoins
mon collègue Savin et puis ce qui a été
dit aussi sur les maîtres nageurs je ne
sais pas si réellement vous avez toutes
les informations qui vous sont remonté
du terrain sur l'état des piscines pour
moi on est dans une situation de tension
beaucoup plus dramatique que ce qui est
laissé supposer dans vos propos il se
trouve que sur mon territoire la piscine
de Longjumeau a fermé la piscine de
l'ittince montlerie à fermé celle d'orsé
que j'is l'honneur de diriger en tant
que maire à failli fermer on se repose
la question pour l'été prochain parce
que c'est pas 300000 ou 1 million
d'euros dont on aurait besoin c'est des
sommes beaucoup plus conséquentes donc
est-ce qu'il faudrait pas quand même
lier les deux questions pour pouvoir
avoir justement comme vous le disiez
vous-même des financements
supplémentaires pour des fonds
d'amorçage qui pourrait servir pour les
piscines qui pourrait aussi servir pour
les maisons sportsanté qui pourrait
servir aussi pour l'université il se
trouve que l'université Paris saclé
classée dans le top 10 de Shangai j'ai
fait savoir à votre collègue habitant de
d'orsé sylvier rotaillot que il a fallu
se battre pour avoir une piste
d'athlétisme sur cette université quand
on regarde par rapport au campus
américain je pense que on est très en
retard alors mes deux questions sonont
les suivantes la première concerne la
sécurité est-ce que il y a une réflexion
concernant j'espère qu'il ne se passera
jamais mais des attaques qui seraient
lié avec des drones quand je suis à
Roland Garos et je pense c'est un
domaine que vous connaissez bien je suis
toujours un peu surpris sur la sécurité
qu' peut y avoir sur menace qui pourrait
être lié par l'usage de drone et on l'
vu en Ukraine à quel point hélas
maintenant ça devient monnaie courante
et la deuxième question elle est plus
mon dada sur le lien alors je vois pas
appître dans les budgets entre la
recherche et le sport comment tout ça
est-il organisé en terme à la fois
d'organisation mais aussi de financement
pour avoir des axes autour du sport
santé de lutte pour améliorer la
motricité et lutter contre le
vieillissement et je terminerai juste en
disant qu'il peut arriver au sénateur
Piednoir de se tromper puisque j'ai
respecté les 3 minutes étant du groupe
socialiste
nous allons passer aux réponses de la
ministre madame la ministre je crois que
toutes les questions ont été posé
évidemment un certain nombre ce se
regroupe ce qui est normal notamment sur
la question du sport universitaire et du
Sport
Santé monsieur le Président euh je vais
commencer par répondre aux questions
relatives aux moyens mobilisés pour nos
athlètes euh h hop je reprends dans
l'ordre
mais hop la liste des questions
3 je m'excuse je trouve le 3 mais je
trouve pas la 1 et la 2 que j'avais il y
a un instant voilà pardon donc
euh la
mobilisation du ministère des Sports et
de l'Agence nationale du sport pour nous
permettre de réussir l'objectif du top 5
prend la forme du programme ambition
bleu mais aussi de cette démarche
spécifique qu'on a appelé gagner en
France par laquelle on mobilise près de
30 millions d'euros additionnels par
pport à nos budgets socle de l'agence
sur la haute performance qui nous
permettent à hauteur de 15 millions
d'euros d'investir dans les sujet de
sitite d'infrastructure d'équipement et
d'utiliser notamment ce qu'on appelle
les rlicas c'est-à-dire la capacité à
permettre à nos athlètes de s'entraîner
sur les matériels cibles des jeux
également 5 millions d'euros sur une
maison de la performance qui leur
permettra de bien se préparer pendant la
période des jeux de s'échauffer de de
pouvoir ensuite faire les débriefs
d'après match les soins et ces
éléments-là 2 millions d'euros qui vont
aussi leur permettre d'avoir accès à une
billetterie renforcée pour ne pas se
soucier sur le plan logistique de la
présence de leur entourage à leur
session également des éléments que nous
mobilisons pour leur permettre d'avoir
un confort un peu meilleur en matière
d'hébergement de transport mais aussi
des budgets relatifs à l'animation les
weekends bleus les séminaires coach les
séminaires aussi que nous mettons en
place autour de pour les cellules
performances les directions techniques
nationales et enfin une application
mobile spécifique qui leur permettra
d'être relié entre eux car on sait que
ce sentiment d'appartenance à une
communauté d'athlètes qui visent tous le
même objectif est quelque chose de très
important on a voulu soigner cet enjeu
là comme on a voulu aussi soigner en
complément les budgets relatifs à la
communication autour de l'équipe de
France unifiée olympique et paralympique
qui aidera le public à mieux découvrir
ses champions et donc à mieux les
encourager mieux les supporter c'est le
sens du club des supporters que nous
sommes également en train de mettre au
point avec les équipes du COJO et les
équipe du CNOSF et du
cpsf sur la Grande Cause
Nationale à grande cause petit budget
non budget inédit jamais une grande
cause n'aura été dédiée de tant de
moyens dans une année avec ses 100
millions d'euros c'est très supérieur à
ce qui s'est fait dans les derniers
exercices et je rappelle que ça vient
bien en complément de l'ensemble des
budgets du ministère j'ai expliqué tout
à l'heure que au titre de la Grande
cause nationale on allait d'abord
conserver un premier pilier qui est
celui d'avoir euh une euh place du sport
au cœur de
l'interministérialité du pacte
républicain et des politiques publiques
donc tous les crédits que nous
mobilisons à hauteur de
828 888 millions d'euros dans ce budget
ça concourra à cette grande cause et les
moyens spécifiques de 100 millions
d'euros correspondent à deux éléments un
élément de communication pour pouvoir
mener des campagnes spécifiques avec
santé-prévention de lutte contre la
sédentarité campagnes réseaux sociaux
digital d'activation des bons messages
de communication en ce sens un peu comme
ça a été fait sur les cinq fruits et
légumes le manger bouger bah on a fait
le manger il faut faire le bouger et le
bouger sera autour des 30 minutes
d'activité comme je l'évoquais tout à
l'heure et l'autre partie de ce
budget sera consacrée à la labellisation
et au financement d'un certain nombre de
projets dans les territoires d'acteurs
qui se diront bah voilà moi je suis un
militant de la grande cause c'est une
grande cause j'ai envie de faire quelque
chose d'exceptionnel pour ce moment un
peu exceptionnel pour la place du sport
en France donc on on financera on
appuiera des initiatives dans les
territoires d'association d'acteurs et
nous labellliserons donc ces ces
démarchesl et peut-être le dernier point
à mentionner à cet égard c'est que
euh et je réponds ça une autre question
qui a été posée tout à l'heure c'est que
la la grande cause nationale c'est aussi
ce que nous nous allons en faire et elle
doit être tourné vers pas seulement
parler des politiques publiques du sport
et cetera mais les vivre les vivre ens
ble et donc déciderz nous de réserver ce
temps pour un peu d'activité physique et
sportive chacun comme il le peut selon
ses moyens ses envies ses préférences
ses facultés et c'est ça qui fera aussi
j'ai envie de dire le l'essence verte
saine de cette grande cause la
mobilisation de chacun d'entre nous y
compris pour une pratique
sportive réelle vécu expérimenté
sur le plan Marshal des des équipements
j'ai j'ai vraiment le sentiment que
cette mobilisation au global si je mets
tout bout à bout le fond vert le DC de
la DETR de plus de 1,2 milliards d'euros
sur la période qui va aller de 2017 à
2027 ressemble vraiment à cette logique
de plan Marshal comme je l'ai dit doublé
d'un travail sur la rénovation
énergétique et thermique des équipements
je suis d'accord sur le fait que
s'agissant du Sport Étudiant on doit
continuer à monter en puissance et c'est
le sens de la feuille de route que le 6
avril dernier j'ai signé avec Sylvie
retaillot à la Cité universitaire à
Paris et également avec France
université et la Conférence des grandes
écoles une des mesures de ce plan
consistait à dire qu'il fallait qu'on
procède à un audit des infrastructure
sportive universitaire cet audit le
ministère des Sports et l'agence vont
l'accompagner ils sera mené dans les
territoires dans les mois qui viennent
et nous en rendrons compte à la
représentation nationale il y a un
certain nombre d'établissements
universitaires qui sont très bien dotés
d'autres qui le sont moins et une autre
dimension de notre politique est
évidemment de travailler sur la
mutualisation des ressources et des
équipements sportifs vous savez que nous
le faisons avec les gymnases qui
bénéficient au scolair en ménageant un
accès indépendant c'était le sens de la
loi du du 2 mars 2022 et les décrets ont
été pris depuis pour sécuriser cela et
c'est le sens également d'autres pans de
notre plan d'action je pense à la mise
en place des villages sport qui sont
destinés à faire connaître l'offre
sportive aux étudiants aux aménagements
que nous promouvons dans les maquettes
universitaires pour laisser y compris
des crédits
eects doter les activités sportives
c'est le sens aussi du challenge
interétud UD que nous animons avec la
Fédération Française de sport
universitair dans la route vers les Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques et de
l'amélioration de la gouvernance sport
et des SUAPS au cœur des universités
pour permettre que cet agenda sportif
qui je suis absolument d'accord avec ce
qui a été dit est essentiel aussi pour
le moral de nos étudiants pour leur
santé leur santé psychologique et donc
une feuille de route résolue en la
matière avec également un fléchage d'une
partie des moyens de la cévec pour ses
activités physiques et
sportives sur le sujet du rapport de la
Cour des comptes j'ai souscrit à
beaucoup des recommandations qui avaient
été faites dans ce rapport et c'est la
raison pour laquelle j'ai vraiment mené
une action très
résolue sur le renforcement de notre
gouvernance à la fois entre le ministère
des Sports et l'agence au niveau
national mais aussi sur l'accélération
de la mise en en place de la gouvernance
territoriale du sport comme vous l'avez
évoqué donc au plan central c'est toute
l'actualisation que nous avons apporté à
la convention d'objectifs et de moyens
c'est le projet commun des membres de la
gouvernance de l'ANS que nous avons mis
en place c'est le protocole de
clarification des rôles et des
responsabilités entre la direction des
sports et l'agence c'est la convention
qui a été signée entre ces deux acteurs
et l'INSEP c'est le décret sur les CREPS
qui là aussi précise les compétences et
les rôles de chacun et sur la
gouvernance territoriale c'est la mise
en place de 17 conférences régionales du
sport contre 14 à l'été dernier c'est
maintenant 15 projets sportifs
territoriaux qui ont été adoptés contre
seulement deux à la même époque l'an
dernier et c'estes 16 conférences des
financeurs installé contre là encore
seulement deux à l'été dernier donc nous
faisons des progrès à pas important mais
on a encore besoin que ces conférences
régionales du sport montent en puissance
et se mobilise au autour de projet
emblématique dans une vraie logique du 1
+ 1 = 3 où les différents niveaux de
collectivité d'une part mais aussi leurs
partenaires que sont les entreprises
privées et le mouvement sportif puissent
vraiment mettre en synergie leurs moyens
et réaliser ensemble des projets qui
n'auraient pas été possible de faire si
chacun avait œuvré
isolément sur le sujet du Stade de
France vous l'avez dit nous sommes
aujourd'hui engagés dans
la
rénovation de le renouvellement des
perspectives s'agissant du Stade de
France avec deux modèle possible le
renouvellement de la concession ou bien
une option de cession à cet égard nous
avons toujours dit qu'il y avait deux
principes directeurs qui nous
guideraient un la nécessité de préserver
la vocation sportive du Stade de France
et le deuxième préserver les intérêts
économiques et financiers de l'État et
en cohérence avec cela le dossier de
consultation des entreprises pose bien
un certain nombre de critères notamment
un critère d'avantage économique global
pour l'état de l'une ou l'autre formule
et un second critère qui est plus
commercial et technique relatif à
l'amélioration de la qualité d'accueil
et plus globalement de l'attractivité du
stade dans son territoire en sens Sani
c'est donc l'ensemble de ces critères
qui seront pris en compte
dans cette nouvelle phase dans laquelle
nous sommes aujourd'hui de la procédure
avec de premières offres des candidats
qui ont été admis dans la première phase
qui seront rendus en janvier prochain
tant sur la partie session que sur la
partie renouvellement de la concession
les discussions ensuite se poursuivront
tout au long de l'année 2024 avec
l'objectif d'aboutir d'ici la fin de
cette année 2024 sur l'un ou l'autre des
modèles en fonction des critères que
j'ai évoqué et donc des offres fermes
qui seront remises par les différents
candidats sur le sujet du travail
illégal dans les chantiers je voudrais
vraiment souligner la mobilisation
particulièrement forte de l'inspection
du travail en la matière plus de 900
contrôles ont déjà été diligentés par
les équipes de la driet sur les
chantiers supervisés par la solideo et
nous avons moins de un
% de cas avérés de travail illégal parmi
les personnes qui ont travaillé sur les
chantiers on peut toujours se dire et je
l'accepte je l'entends que 1 % c'est
trop mais c'est quand même extrêmement
performant comme niveau de régularité
sur ces chantiers et je précise que en
correspondance d'ailleurs avec cette
approche vertueuse de la solidéo à
laquelle tient personnellement Nicolas
Ferran c'est que nous avons eu aussi une
accidentologie très faible sur ces
chantiers divisé par 5 par rapport au
chantier de même envergure
traditionnellement et je touche du bois
aucun accident mortel pour le moment sur
ces chantiers on continue la solideo
mobilise des outils y compris digitaux
sans précédent btivigi notamment qui
sont déployés sur l'ensemble des sites
et également avec les partenaires sur
lesquels elle s'appuie en matière de
maîtrise
d'ouvrage sur euh le sujet de
l'athlétisme oui c'est un sujet vous le
savez qui me tient vraiment à cœur
j'avais pu débrifé aussitôt après
Budapest avec les équipes de la
fédération de l'agence le directeur de
la haute performance Romain Barras et je
leur avais promis de participer à leur
séminaire ce que j'ai fait il y a
quelques jours en me connectant avec eux
ils étaient présents à saint-malot pour
bien débriffer des prochaines étapes qui
vont les mener à la fin de l'année vers
euh un grand temps de rassemblement tous
ensemble à pchestroom et ensuite sur
différentes épreuves entre le début
d'année 2024 et la mi-224 la
mobilisation inédite de la cellule
d'optimisation de la performance des
moyens en terme de suivi médical de
suivi athlétique et de suivi en matière
de nutrition qui sont renforcés par la
Fédération et un consensus aujourd'hui
sur le fait qu'on a pas un manque de
moyens qu'il faut donc maintenant être
bien à fond sur l'activation de tous ses
leviers sur une programmation ambitieuse
tout en faisant très attention à la
santé des athlètes pour éviter les cas
de blessures qui se sont produit je
pense à Kevin Mayer et à Renault
lavillennie pendant Budapest et qu'on
essaye aussi d'avoir de l'optimisme dans
le sens où la performance d'un Sacha
Zoya une Alice fino en 5000 styple ou de
notre relais qui a été Infiné médaillé
augure aussi de très belles opportunités
pour les jeux de Paris on deviendra pas
en un cl m dois une très grande nation
de l'athlétisme mais on est une nation
majeure de l'athlétisme européen et il
faut qu'on ait notre juste part des
médailles à Paris
s'agissant du
rugby je voudrais souligner le
formidable engouement populaire dont
elle a été l'objet dont elle continue
d'être l'objet nous aurons la petite
finale comme on l'appelle vendredi soir
entre l'Angleterre et l' Argentine un
remake des matchs de pool nous aurons
cette très grande finale entre les
springbx et les Blacks samedi
soir qui va nous rappeler
1995 des pics d'audience qui ont été
jusqu'à plus de 17 millions de
spectateurs de téléspectateurs pardon en
France mondialement on va consolider
l'ensemble de ces audiences il y a
également une explosion de la
fréquentation des plateformes digitales
avec des chiffres qui là non plus N
jamais été observé auparavant une
fréquentation extrêmement forte de
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
spectateurs dans les fans zone qui ont
été mis en place à travers les neuf
collectivités hautes des records
également en matière de merchandising
puisque même après la défaite de
l'équipe de France les maillots de cette
équipe ont continué à être achetés
massivement par les spectateurs de la
Coupe du monde de rugby alors oui quand
on sait le potentiel exceptionnel de
cette équipe qu'on sait en plus
tellement attachante bien sûr qu'on a un
déchirement par rapport à ce qui s'est
passé à forceie quand on sait que ça
n'est que d'un point que cette défaite a
été concédée mais il faut retenir que
cette équipe a énormément d'avenir
qu'elle a un sélectionneur qui a fait un
formidable travail depuis 4 ans qui va
continuer et une fédération aujourd'hui
très déterminée à l'accompagné dans les
années à venir pour permettre à cette
équipe qui est une très grande équipe
d'avoir enfin la victoire la première
victoire dans une coupe du monde de
rugby il y aura d'autres épreuves d'ici
là y compris le rugby à 7 aux Jeux
Olympiques vous l'avez en tête pour
lesquels j'espère que notre Antoine
Dupont pourra faire partie de notre
équipe de France et bien évidemment
aussi notre équipe de rugby fauteuil qui
là aussi d'un maudit point un point à
nouveau n'a pas réussi à monter sur le
podium pendant la Coupe Internationale
de rugby fauteuil que pour la première
fois nous organisions en mar d'une coupe
du monde de rugby mais une très belle
équipe avec de très bons éléments un
sélectionneur et un entraîneur
extrêmement déterminé et qui j'en suis
sûre arriveront à décrocher un podium au
Jeux Paralympique de
sur le
sujet de l'efficacité de la dépense dans
le sport et de l'euro investi moi je
voudrais souligner que c'est ma culture
que c'est la démarche dans laquelle j'ai
inscrit mon ministère avec notre
notamment ce fasciicule que j'ai diffusé
à l'été
2023 dans lequel je rends compte de
manière extrêmement transparente de
l'atteinte de nos objectifs de manière
chiffrée et dans lequel j'expose les
prochaines étapes de nos politiques sur
chacune des thématiques prioritaires et
je veux ajouter que s'agissant des Jeux
olympiques et
paralympiques nous aurons une action
spécifique puisque
13 études d'impact sont prévu pour
montrer l'impact des investissements que
nous consentons depuis plusieurs années
pour les préparer à la fois sur la haute
performance sur la montée en puissance
de la pratique sportive sur l'analyse
également des retombées économiques bien
sûr de ces jeux sur l'accessibilité en
matière de pratique pour les personnes
en situation de handicap et et un focus
spécifique qui sera fait sur la scène
saint n à la fois sous l'angle du
rattrapage économique mais aussi sous
l'angle de la mesure de la compétence en
natation en 6e et de son écart à la
moyenne nationale donc nous rendrons des
comptes très précis sur toutes ces
thématiques qui permettront de mesurer
l'efficacité de l'euro investi pas
seulement avec les politique publique du
sport mais aussi avec l'argent investi
dans les jeux olympiques et
paralympiques
sur le sujet de l'aisance
aquatique c'est en effet un sujet
prioritaire et on ne peut pas se
satisfaire d'une situation où nous
continuons d'avoir 1000 noyades par an
c'est le premier motif de décès par
accident de la vie courante et il frappe
massivement les enfants à hauteur de 25
%. c'est pourquoi nous menons une
politique résolue en la matière et je
voudrais souligner que nous avons déjà
pu délivrer 50 30000 attestations pour
l'aisance aquatique qui concerne le
programme des 4 à 6 ans et 72000
formations pour la tranche des 6 12 ans
sur j'apprends à nager le soutien de
l'agence à ces deux dispositifs
représente 4 millions d'euros récurrents
et nous sommes là-dessus résolus à
continuer à monter en puissance et en
effet le programme en faveur des
investissements pour les piscines nous
aidera à le faire de la même façon et je
voudrait vraiment le souligner que nous
avons apporté une évolution
réglementaire très importante puisque le
4 juin dernier j'ai publié avec le
ministère de l'Intérieur un décret qui
permet d'octroyer la surveillance en
autonomie dans toutes nos dans toutes
nos piscines et nos lieux de Beade au
titulaire d'un BNSSA le brevet national
de sécurité et de sauvetage aquatique et
donc ces ressourcesl viennent en
complément de NS m nageur sauteur qui
eux par contre conservent le monopole
des activités encadrées et de
l'enseignement de la natation donc
surveillance d'un côté enseignement de
l'autre et il sera vous avez
parfaitement raison de le souligner
extrêmement important dans la
perspective de l'été 24 de faire monter
en puissance la mobilisation des BNSSA
et de poursuivre nos campagnes de
promotion et d'attractivité du métier de
ma nageor sauvteur à cela va également
euh aider les travaux conduits par
Stanislas Guerini autour de
l'attractivité des métiers de la
fonction publique qui auront de fait un
impact sur la profession de mns qui est
exercé à 80 % dans la fonction publique
territoriale sur le sujet du sport santé
qui est très important vous savez que
nous avons déjà déployé
573 maisons sport santé on continue à
monter en puissance avec des moyens
supplémentaires consacrés à cette
thématique dans le PL F sur le
remboursement de la prescription
médicale nous menons aujourd'hui des
travaux avec Aurélien Rousseau et agès
firmain lebudau sous l'égide de la
première ministre pour continuer à
travailler dans la promotion du sport
sur ordonnance et prévoir qu'on aille
au-delà des dispositifs actuels qui pour
l'instant peuvent rembourser sur
certains parcours de soins des
consultations ou des bilan mais pas
encore les séances d'app et nous sommes
en train de travailler sur cette
thématique là pour que par exemple dans
des parcours relatifs au traitement du
cancer on puisse rembourser un certain
nombre de cours d'activité physique
adapté de la même façon que nous
poursuivons notre travail sur le bilan
médico-social de la vingtaine
d'expérimentation qui intègre de l'AP
aujourd'hui au titre des fameuses
expérimentations de l'article 51 et on
va faire en sorte que à chaque fois que
ces expérimentations auront été jugées
probantes elles puissent être le plus
possible passer dans le ressort du droit
commun sur le sujet du Pass sport vous
savez que nous sommes engagés résolument
dans trois voies la première c'est
l'extension que je mentionnais tout à
l'heure à de nouveaux public comme les
étudiants boursiers 800000 étudiants
boursiers et aussi des structures les
associations jeunesse et éducation
populaires les
associations sport les structures du
loisir sportifs marchands qui sont
signataires avec nous d'une charte
d'engagement et les deux autres leviers
sur lesquels nous agissons c'est
l'information la sensibilisation des
bénéficiaires en veillant à ce que ils
identifient bien les codes individuel en
ligne qu'ils peuvent télécharger sur le
portail usager ce qu'il doiv faire en
cas de perte de non réception de ce code
individuel et nous travaillons également
c'est le troisème point avec et pour les
structures avec la simplification i de
l'outil le compte assaut qui permet de
demander le remboursement du passeport
un remboursement qui grâce à l'agence
des services et des paiements
aujourd'hui est effectué de manière plus
rapide on va continuer dans ce sens-là
on a beaucoup d'ambitions pour ce
dispositif j'entends tout à fait la
question du reste à charge qui c'est
vrai peut se poser pour un certain
nombre de familles ou un certain nombre
de sports mais qui aujourd'hui connaî
des réponses satisfaisantes le point sur
lequel on est c'est vraiment la
connaissance et la diffusion de cet
outil qui aujourd'hui ne trouve pas
encore suffisamment son public alors
même que de nouvelles extensions
d'éligibilité ont été
effectuées
sur le sujet
euh du sport féminin là encore un plan à
plusieurs niveau qui commence dès les
cours de récréation
avec des investissements faits en faveur
des cours d'école actifes pour qu'on
arrive à éliminer les stéréotypes genrés
que les écarts de
pas qui
aujourd'hui
déséquilibre petits garçons et petites
filles dans les cours d'école avec des
petits garçons qui ont tendance à
monopoliser les espaces et les terrains
de grands jeux dans les cours de de
récréation puissent apporter des
solutions pratiques à cela tous les pays
qui ont de très bons résultats en
matière de promotion de la pratique
sportive féminine ont comm cer par cette
étape là dès les cours de récréation une
grosse priorité au niveau des
adolescentes il faut qu'on évite le
décrochage c'est le sens de la promotion
des activités Ludos sportives dans le
cadre notamment des As mais aussi des 2
heures supplémentaires pour les
collégiens on travaille avec santé
publique France à l'enrichissement de la
plateforme 1000 premiers jours pour
permettre aux jeunes mamans de ne pas
abandonner la pratique d'une activité
sportive à l'arrivée d'un un enfant et
même de se servir du sport pour se
réathlétiser de la même façon que nous
menons une activité résolue pour
permettre d'attribuer des aides à la
parentalité à nos jeunes mamans et les
encourager dans des quand elles sont des
championnes à ne pas redouter la
maternité à l'assumer pleinement comme
l'a fait Claris créer comme l'a fait
notre athlète paralympique manonjeunesse
comme l'a fait Claris agbignénou et donc
d'avoir une approche beaucoup plus
moderne
de la haute performance pour les jeunes
mamans c'est aussi une philosophie qui a
été placée par Hervé Renard au cœur de
notre équipe de France de football
féminine vous l'avez suivi s'agissant du
renforcement de la médiatisation je
crois que vous connaissez mon combat en
la matière les engagements que je suis
allé chercher auprès des diffuseurs dans
le cadre de la Coupe du Monde Féminine
cet été et nous allons poursuivre en ce
sens avec la perspective du décret
relatif aux événements d'importance
majeure qui nous permettra d'améliorer
it la diffusion en clair du sport
féminin sur le foot sur le rugby sur le
Tour de France féminin mais également
sur d'autres disciplines comme le
handbal
peut-être deux derniers point si le
compte est bon sur les financements en
faveur des clubs je voudrais vraiment
rappeler qu'en complément des 120
millions d'euros mobilisés par l'agence
au service de la haute performance nous
avons tout t les moyens mobilisés pour
les projets sportifs fédéraux 75
millions d'euros qui vont directement au
180000 clubs de notre pays plus une
démarche spécifique que nous cofinançons
pour les clubs parasport les clubs dit
inclusif que nous voulons faire passer
d'à peu près 1000 aujourd'hui à 4000 à
l'horizon des
jeux sur le musée il existe un musée
aujourd'hui dédié au sport le Musée
National du Sport j'y tiens beau
beaucoup il est présidé par Vincent
duuluc il est dirigé par Marie grass il
bénéficie de concours important du
ministère des Sports il contenait il
comportait une très belle exposition à
l'honneur de la Coupe du monde de rugby
il sera bien évidemment au couleur de la
grande cause et des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques en
2024 enfin et ce sera mon tout dernier
point sur les 5 clubs sur les 122 il
faut utiliser des chiffres qui soient
récent et non pas se référer à des
chiffres passés et dépassés et je veux
redire que nous avons un programme de
contrôle qui porte sur 6000
établissements et rappeler également
qu'aujourd'hui les données le montrent
dans le fichier
fsprt le nombre de fiches actives en
lien avec le sport est passé de 1000 en
2019 à 550 en 2021 sur environ environ
8000 fiches c'est-à-dire 7 % du stock
nous sommes bien dans un mouvement de
régression sur ces sujetsl et dans une
volonté farouche de ne laisser aucun cas
perdurer quand on détecte une dérive
séparatiste donc nous contrôlons le
respect du contrat d'engagement
républicain nous retirons des
subventions en lien avec les fédérations
et notamment avec le conseil de de la
région î-de-france que je veux saluer
sur cette action résolue menée avec nous
sur le territoire de l'île-de-fance de
la même façon que nous suspendons les
agréments ou que nous fermons si
nécessaire les établissements
concernés merci madame la ministre nous
avons fini notre audition je crois que
tous ceux qui voulaient s'exprimer l'ont
l'ont fait merci de vos réponses précis
à nos questions et donc nous allons
poursuivre nos travaux et je me tourne
vers notre rapporteur budgétaire
poursuivre notre nos travaux sur
l'examen des des crédits sport du du du
PLF que nous aurons examiné en
commission dans quelques jours merci
Madame la Ministre merci
beaucoup merci à
vous que j'ou une
question